All right, so now that we have our player pawn set up
to actually receive a score and a time pickup,
it's now actually time to create that pickup.
And we're gonna be doing this
by first creating a new blueprint
and using actor as the parent class.
Let's just pop over into the editor,
hit control space to bring up my content browser.
And then I'm gonna come again up to my content folder,
just gonna right click in here, blueprint class,
and then base this off of actor.
I'm gonna call this BP underscore pickup.
Once we have done that,
the next thing that we're going to do
is we are going to open up our blueprint
and add a sphere collision in a static mesh.
And we're gonna set the static mesh shape to Taurus.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So again, we're gonna come here,
we're gonna open up our BP pickup.
And then on the components,
we're gonna click on this add
and we're gonna look for a sphere collision, okay?
And then we're gonna click on add again,
and we're gonna look for a static mesh, there we go.
Then for our static mesh, I'm gonna come over here
and we're gonna look for a, I don't know,
let's just use this arcade sphere right here.
And I think that's actually a little bit too big.
So what we're gonna do is I come here to the scale
and I'm just gonna 0.25, maybe 0.1.
Yeah, there we go, that works.
So 0.1, scale that down a little bit.
So that is perfect.
Now, the next thing that we need to do
is we are going to select our sphere
and then we're going to go to the events
and we're gonna press the on component begin overlap.
What this is gonna do is this is going
to automatically create an event for us
that is going to fire off
once something has begin to overlap this component.
So very simply, we're gonna grab this sphere right here,
our sphere collision, I'm gonna scroll down
and keep on going right here to our events.
I'm gonna say this on component begin overlap.
I'm gonna press this plus sign right here,
which is gonna kick us over to the event graph,
adding to that node
and then focusing us right there on that node.
Now with that node added,
the next thing that we need to do
is we're gonna do a check to make sure
that the item that we're running over
does implement our interface.
And then if we do, we are going to basically make a call
and then set our score and our time.
Now, the reason that we're making sure
that when we overlap this particular actor
that it implements our interface,
it could be very easy
that you have a player pawn or an AI pawn
and you don't want the AI pawn to interact with this,
you only want the player or maybe you don't.
In our case, we only want the player.
So we do wanna make sure
that whatever interacts with this pickup object,
that it does have our interface in it.
So to do this, we're gonna come here
and we are going to first off of our other actors,
we're gonna look for does
and then right there does implement interface.
And the interface that we're gonna be checking for
is our, if I just type in BPI,
we're gonna find it right there, a BPI stats interface.
Then what we're gonna do
is this is returning a Boolean values.
Remember Booleans are true or false.
So we're gonna look for a branch
and then under utilities flow control,
we're gonna add a branch.
You can also add a branch quickly
by pressing the B key on the keyboard and left clicking
that will add the branch node as well.
And with our branch added,
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna connect the execution
of our on component begin overlap
to the input on our branch.
Oops, missed that input, there we go.
And again, I only want this to fire off
if we do implement that interface.
So I'm gonna take the return value
from our does implement interface
and plug that into our condition.
And this is gonna make us a check.
Next, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna pull off of the true here
because we want to make sure that when this is true,
we actually do something
and we're gonna go pick up object
and we want this message.
So the message is going to allow us to basically say,
hey, I have received this,
what do you want me to do with it?
And for us, what we're gonna do here
is first things first,
we're gonna take this other actor
and we're gonna plug this into target.
This is just ensuring that we are actually working
on the correct and with the correct interface,
I'm also adding to reroute nodes
to make it a little bit easier just to read this graph.
Now, this score and time pickup
is gonna be something that is placeable
by a level designer or level artist.
So next thing that we're gonna do
is we are going to expose some parameters,
more specifically for our score and time,
we are gonna make these both instance edible.
So to do that, this is really, really simple.
What we're gonna do is we're just gonna right click
on the score and promote to variable
and then I'm gonna pull this down like so,
and then do the same thing for the time,
promote to variable,
and I'm gonna pull this one down as well.
So I'm gonna just stack these right over here.
Now I do need to compile and save this, there we go.
And last but not least, again,
I want these to be editable
when this is placed inside of a level.
So to do that, we're gonna come here
and we're gonna make these variables public
by pressing this little I right here,
it will now be editable
once we have placed it inside of our level.
So we're gonna go ahead and save.
And the last thing that we need to do with this
is we're gonna add this destroy actor.
Now what this will do is this will destroy this actor
or remove it from the gameplay level
once we have finished.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're gonna come here
and we are going to just drag off of this
and look for destroy and there's our destroy actor.
So again, just to recap,
we first added our sphere and our sphere collision, okay?
And then we shrunk our sphere down to a point one
because it's a little bit small.
We then grabbed our sphere right here
and then in our details panel,
we came over and on component begin overlap
was added to our event graph.
We then check to see if the component
or the object that we're overlapping
has our interface and if it does,
we are then gonna make a call to give a default score
and a default amount of time.
And then we're gonna destroy this.
The last thing that we need to do here
for our integer and our time, our score and our time,
I'm just gonna set the default values of these to five.
We don't necessarily need to do this
but with everything that we have going on at one time,
this will make sure that once we go to test this,
things will work and then we're not sitting there stuck
scratching our heads wondering why something isn't working.
So this does it for this particular section
of our video tutorial series.
Up next, we're gonna be taking a more in-depth look
at setting up Unreal Motion Graphics
and then how we're gonna wire all of this together
to our Blueprints.